♪ Bad bitch, bad bitch, bad bitch, ♪
mother-f--king bad bitch.♪
There was no one like Heather.
There's no question about it.
She says, "I'm many things."
"A rapper, an economist..."
"A journalist..."
"A writer..."
♪ A CEO and a dirty,
dirty, dirty dirty ho. ♪
Is this a joke?
If it is a joke, is it funny?
The department has
charged Ilya Lichtenstein
and Heather Morgan for their alleged roles
in a conspiracy to launder
stolen cryptocurrency
taken during the 2016 hack of
a virtual currency exchange.
It's almost like you're
watching a movie unfold.
When Heather and Dutch were arrested,
we realized that this was
possibly the biggest heist
in the history of the world.
But when we looked at
it, we were like, 'wait,
this is the alleged conspirator
of a billion dollar crypto heist?'
Bitfinex is one of the biggest
cryptocurrency exchanges in the world.
In August 2016, Bitfinex got hacked.
Somebody broke into their computer system
and was able to access the keys,
which are like the
cryptographic passwords,
to the Bitcoins that they
hold for their customers.
And they transferred these
Bitcoins to other wallets.
And before anyone noticed what happened
about half the exchanges'
Bitcoin had been transferred.
So Bitfinex had to shut down the exchange.
Obviously the customers
were really worried.
They announced that they'd been hacked
and that a lot of the
customer funds were lost.
The hackers stole 119,754 Bitcoins.
I believe at one point the pile was worth
as much as $8 billion.
Just like an insane amount
of money for anyone to have.
This is a story that very
much plays out on social media
and I think that is the
reason why it hit our desk.
Tonight, I want to talk about
the Bitcoin Bitfinex hackers
or money launderers.
Something doesn't feel right.
I will show you what people have found.
When I started Googling,
like everybody else
on the internet, I realized
that they didn't seem
like the sharpest criminals.
And in this episode,
we're talking about these two idiots.
What really triggered our interest
was these videos that started going around
showing Heather Morgan,
who is one of the alleged
conspirators in this crypto heist,
rapping about being the
crocodile of Wall Street
in these really weird
music videos that were
all of a sudden making
rounds across social media.
♪ Mother-f--king
crocodile of Wall Street ♪
♪ Silver on my fingers
and boots on my feet ♪
The Bitcoin crimes are nothing compared
to calling this sh-t rap.
I definitely wanted to
dig into it and know more.
Heather grew up in a
tiny town in California.
It was about a couple hundred
people that lived there
and as she was living there,
she really craved getting out.
Growing up, I did not
have a lot of friends
and it was really hard
because no one was trying to
do the things I wanted
to do professionally
as far as entrepreneurship,
technology, seeing the world.
And as soon as she graduated,
she got out of the country.
She did a short stint in Hong Kong
and then found her way in Cairo,
where she was trying to
get a master's degree
in international economics.
But remember, this was back in 2011.
This was a time when tech
was really taking off.
San Francisco was really
booming and I think, for her,
it really became clear very
soon that if she wanted
to become something she had
to move back to California.
I met Heather about eight
years ago at 500 Startups.
It's a startup incubator
based out of the Bay Area.
Man, I haven't seen
these faces for so long.
That's a good picture.
Heather's right there, you can see. Right?
Everybody's like upbeat.
Everybody's optimistic.
And everybody's looking for
that, you know, next break.
Heather really enjoyed that environment.
She was very in tune
with, you know everybody,
what's going on around her,
interacting with all these
different kinds of people,
different founders, different
investors, VCs, mentors.
She was always there.
Personality-wise, like, super friendly,
very bubbly, very ambitious, very helpful.
She was like a fish in water there.
This principal who was also
my teacher, he told me,
"Listen. You're a big
fish in a small pond.
But if you go to the
ocean you might drown."
The ocean, yeah, it's big but I'm a shark.
I belong in the ocean, not
in a mud puddle or a pond.
That's around the time that
she meets Ilya Lichtenstein,
who goes by Dutch.
My name is Ilya Lichtenstein,
I'm the co-founder of
a start called Mixrank.
Dutch is someone who grew up in Chicago
but was born in Russia.
His family were Russian immigrants
and he really was someone
who, in high school,
was describing himself as a nerd.
He was captain of the math
team and really didn't have,
you know, really good social skills.
When he was in college, I
saw that he posted a lot
on forums about affiliate marketing
and this is sort of
like the the shady side
of internet marketing
where you're posting ads
about like, miracle diet pills
or like, can't miss investment tips.
I think his specialty
was adult dating sites.
He was bragging that
when he was in college,
he was making more than a
hundred thousand dollars a year
from this affiliate marketing.
Dutch then went from that
to starting a company
that was in this internet marketing space
that was more legit.
They raised money from
some angel investors.
Well we're at a really exciting place
as a company right now
because we are at a point
where we have initial product-market fit,
we have good revenue growth,
we have over a hundred customers-
According to reports
that we saw out there,
even though Dutch's company
was doing super well,
one day in 2016 he just quit.
He packed up all his things with Heather
and they moved to New York City.
And I think that became a
really interesting date,
for prosecutors as well,
because that's around the time
when the Bitfinex hack happened.
The reality is that a lot of those hacks
are not the most sophisticated hacks
that you would see in
the cybersecurity space.
A lot of them really rely
on social engineering
and that's kind of the
entry point for the hackers
to obtain access to the internal systems,
the IT infrastructure, of
the compromised target.
In social engineering attacks, the victim,
which is usually the
employee of the company,
is being persuaded by the hackers
through some kind of an
email message, a phone call,
sometimes even a video
chat to do some interaction
which will open malicious files
on their desktop or laptop.
I've been writing forever.
And I've been sending cold emails,
at least sending one a day
for more than 10 years now.
So I've definitely written
more than 10,000 cold emails.
And once that file is open,
the attackers are able to
implant and to install a malware
that once installed
provides them full access
to that computer.
I like to do what I call
e-stalking. Going on LinkedIn.
Twitter works too if they're on Twitter
And if that computer is
not properly isolated
and has access to the entire network,
they're able to propagate to
other components in the network
or to access other really
sensitive resources.
And a little pro tip for LinkedIn
is to look on their references.
Who they're referring and
who has referred them.
Because those are actually
really rich with keywords
and gives you a good
sense of how they talk.
That was also the case
in the Bitfinex hacks
but also like, you know,
in many hacks that you see even today.
Heather embarks on a multitude
of different activities, including
running her tech company,
and it essentially offers
businesses services
for cold emailing and for
branching out and marketing.
You can influence people a lot of ways.
You can influence them with flattery,
by adding value to them, bribing them,
you can also influence them with fear.
And so she's going around New York
and she's actually giving
talks and presentations
to people who are showing
up to hear her advice.
And in 2019, perhaps one
of the most notable ones
was one that she gave at
the Williamsburg Hotel
called "How to Social Engineer
Your Way into Anything."
Social Engineering is basically,
I hate the term manipulating,
but it's getting someone
to share information
or take an action that
they otherwise would not.
And some of these in hindsight
just were all very funny
'cause it was almost like
she's telling on herself.
So I like to think of social
engineers as underdogs.
A lot of times if you
don't have an advantage
you have to create one for yourself.
I mean, she's great at cold emails,
she's great at manipulating people.
Is it such a stretch to think
that she could have
participated in, you know,
sending a phishing email
to a crypto exchange?
As soon as they moved to New York City,
they ended up living in an
apartment on Wall Street.
It was a million dollar apartment.
It's like a pretty
normal-looking apartment.
Well, no, it's not normal-looking at all
because Heather decorated it.
The apartment's full of
like weird knickknacks
that she's collected,
like crocodile skulls
or something she called
Ukrainian sewer rocks.
They had an elliptical but
she painted it like a zebra.
I mean they seem like they
have a lot of fun together
like around the financial district,
traveling, going to restaurants.
It wasn't like they were living
like a billionaire lifestyle
but they were definitely
spending a fair amount of money.
You'd think that somebody
who allegedly laundered
billions of dollars
would try to keep a low profile
but Heather actually seemed
to be trying to turn herself
into some kind of like
internet famous personality.
Heather started appearing
across social media
with an alter ego.
That alter ego was named
Razzlekhan and she was a rapper.
Moon in stars, we don't own cars.
F--k the pandemic, in the pandemic.
Party like a Beiruti, labne and tabouleh.
Bitch, I'm the mother-f--king
crocodile of Wall Street.
Wall Street!
Razzle dazzle.
There are few people I've
come across in my life
that you just say like,
there's nobody like them.
Heather is one of them.
She was a frequent guest at our gallery.
She was fun, she was always
entertaining, good to be around.
I remember distinctly the day she told me
that she wanted to become a hip hop artist
and then started to rap.
And when I heard that, those words,
that's what shocked me.
They were some of the most
vile, mind-blowing concepts.
It fits totally into Heather.
It's just unapologetic.
She rapped about smoking
her grandfather's ashes
at a graveyard. That was colorful.
Masturbating a horse.
But also rapped about finance
bros and like on Wall Street,
and misogyny, and all those things.
It was almost a challenge.
It was how can you keep a straight face
when she's keeping a
straight face free-styling,
being completely who she is.
And she was really serious
about being a hip hop artist.
But also I couldn't keep myself composed.
Like motha' f--kin' pond scum.
She would kind of smirk
when I was smirking
but she wasn't joking about this stuff.
Your real self is always your
best self. Razzle dazzle!
Stay awkward and weird!
I never really thought about
where she's getting the money from
but when I heard the music,
the first thing that did
come into my head was,
who's paying for this production?
It's not that bad of production,
it has to cost some money.
♪ Mother-f--King crocodile
of Wall Street- ♪
I love you, I support you,
but I don't wanna be involved.
It's a private club and you ain't in it.
Dutch is sort of in the background.
He's like reluctantly on camera,
he kind of complains about it.
Are you just keep filming me
expecting something to happen?
What do you want me to do?
You want me to just like
shove something up my ass?
When he decided to propose to her,
he essentially hired a marketing agency
to put up posters of Razzlekhan
around New York City.
The campaign described Heather as someone
who captured the essence of Razzlekhan.
"Surreal, mysterious, creepy, and sexy?"
I think the fact that they really sort of
craved that attention was
also visible at their wedding
with social media videos that circulated
from the day of the ceremony
showing Heather rapping
throughout the ceremony.
But perhaps the most interesting thing was
that she was carried down the aisle
while sitting on a
throne, by eight people,
while "Final Countdown" was
playing in the background.
Heather and Dutch, they
would've known something was up
because they'd been notified
by their internet service provider
that someone had asked for their records
through a legal request.
After the hack, Bitfinex
publicized the addresses
that the hackers had used.
This was to put everybody on alert
so that they didn't do any
deals with those bitcoins.
It's almost like setting off the dye pack
in the bag of stolen money
after a bank robbery.
So the hackers had all these Bitcoins,
but it'd be difficult to find someone
who wanted to handle them
because now they're sort
of marked as dirty money.
So they needed some sort
of less ethical player
that didn't mind accepting payments
from their marked accounts.
And for five months the
coins didn't move at all.
Then they found somebody who was willing
to take at least some of them.
This less picky business
was called AlphaBay.
Kind of like a eBay on the dark web
where you can buy drugs, guns, whatever.
So obviously the administrator
of this underworld eBay
tried to keep his identity secret.
As it turned out, it was
a 25 year old Canadian
named Alexander Cazes who
was living in Thailand.
So the Bitfinex hackers first sent funds
to AlphaBay in January, 2017.
What they didn't know is that AlphaBay
was already the target of this
international investigation
called Operation Bayonet.
And just a few months later in July,
Royal Thai Police raided Cazes's compound
and so they were able to
access all of AlphaBay's files.
When you send the money to AlphaBay,
you're like sending it into this box
and when you withdraw
it no one can tell like
where it came from exactly.
But now the FBI has the box,
they look inside and they
can make all the connections
between the deposits and the withdrawals.
So if you are able to track
the cryptocurrency transactions
and eventually the hacker is sloppy,
or didn't really think about
how they're going to cash out,
the cryptocurrency that
they were able to steal
then they would authenticate themselves
with a financial institution,
let's say a centralized exchange,
a FinTech app or something like that,
through which they will try to convert
say, the bitcoins, to regular cash.
The police or the law enforcement
agencies can now identify
who was trying to basically
cash out the funds.
At least in some cases, some
of the money went to accounts
that had been opened by
Dutch using his real name.
Presumably he thought this would never
be traced back to the hacked funds.
But the raid on AlphaBay
I think made it possible
to make the connection.
94,000 Bitcoin, that is $3.6 billion.
On Tuesday, police in New York
arrested a husband and wife couple
that allegedly tried to
launder just that amount.
When the indictment came out-
I got a text message
from my business partner being
like, you need to see this.
I clicked on it and I saw a picture.
It just popped up right there
saying, okay, such and such.
But then I said, Heather
Morgan, I know that name.
And then when I clicked on it, you know,
their photo was there. I
was like, oh my goodness.
This blew my mind.
I immediately messaged her
like, "Dude, what's going on?"
It was January 5th, 2022.
Heather's parents were visiting
and obviously Heather
and Dutch had no idea
that these agents were coming on this day.
These FBI and IRS agents
come into Heather and Dutch's apartment,
start taking their electronic devices.
The agents described the
search in a court filing
and at some point Heather says,
"This is taking a long
time. We'd like to leave,
but can we take our Bengal
cat Clarissa with us?"
She crouches down next to the bed
and tries to get Clarissa out.
But it was actually kind of a trick
'cause what she really wanted
to do was grab her cell phone
off the nightstand, she
starts hitting lock,
but the agents are right there,
able to get the cell phone from her.
They found burner phones,
hollowed-out books,
all sorts of electronics.
The authorities had also gotten warrants
to search Dutch's cloud storage accounts.
And in this, they found evidence
that they'd been
preparing fake identities,
it looked like maybe they were
planning to flee the country.
And by the end of the
month, on January 31st,
they were able to crack the
encryption to one of his files
which had all the passwords
to the Bitcoin wallets
that held the stolen Bitcoins.
This was like the jackpot.
This is what they were looking for
because it doesn't necessarily prove
that Dutch was the hacker
but somehow he'd come into
possession of these passwords
and whoever has the passwords,
controls the Bitcoins.
And by this point, they're
worth billions of dollars.
And so all of a sudden,
these two quirky, awkward
individuals that post seemingly,
you know, innocent videos
across social media,
have become these two individuals
that allegedly conspire to
launder $4.5 billion in crypto,
what the DOJ describes
as their largest financial seizure ever.
I couldn't believe it.
It didn't seem real,
knowing the kind of person
she is.
She's kind, she's thoughtful,
she's interesting,
she's all these things but maybe she
doesn't realize that this isn't a movie.
I'm not defending anything. Right?
People do weird things
and some take it too far.
Yo, razzle dazzle.
In terms of general scrutiny
that the women have to go through
is definitely much harder than guys.
And that's the same with Heather's case,
now I see is that everybody's just focused
on the entertainment aspect of it.
Do you ever wanna get f--ked up?
First thing that came out
is all about, 'oh, you know,
look at, you know, the
rapping and this and that.
Probably crazy.'
So immediately the objectivity
of the case itself is kind of lost.
In the crypto world almost
nothing shocks me anymore
but this was definitely pretty surprising.
This is a world where all sorts of peoples
are getting rich and
then losing it overnight.
You have a crypto scam,
you have TikTok videos going viral.
You have that hype and that need
to be sort of a celebrity
across social media.
And so really these are all the forces
that came together to
create a crypto heist
that was made for the digital times.
I would say that the big exchanges
seem to have tightened their security
but then the hackers have
also stepped up their game.
We are seeing the hackers really moving
into the area of DeFi
protocol, Web3 organizations,
gaming companies that are
using cryptocurrencies
because they're the new targets for them.
The fact that social
engineering still happens today
and it's the number one entry point.
That's definitely true.
I went down to the
courthouse where Heather
and Dutch would've gone
for their pretrial hearing.
And on a traffic pole right across
from where she likely
would've walked into court,
there was a sticker, one of the same ones
that she'd posted all over
the financial district,
that showed Razzlekhan riding a crocodile.
Who knows, maybe she's
riding the crocodile
off into the sunset.
♪ We're too weird for average Joes ♪
♪ Everyone knows you're the best for me ♪
♪ This is how our story goes ♪
♪ This is the Razzlekhan
and Dutchie shows ♪
♪ Ready to party down
and let's get weird ♪
♪ Moon and stars, moon and stars, moon ♪
♪ And stars, stars, stars ♪